He's just sort of part
of the musical furniture
of American culture.
It's just wallpaper.
With Kenny G's music, what can you say?
Kenny G, the curly-maned saxophonist
who has sold 75 million
records and inspired
the entire genre of smooth jazz
isn't just the best-selling
instrumentalist of all time.
He's also one of the
most critically reviled
musicians in history.
And he's the subject of
the new HBO documentary,
"Listening to Kenny G,"
which The New Yorker called
an ironic masterpiece
that perfectly defines
the elusive and contested
concept of a guilty pleasure.
In "Listening to Kenny
G," director Penny Lane
explores why critics hate Kenny
G and the masses love him,
creating a funny poignant
and entrancing conversation
about mass commercial
appeal and elite tastes.
When I think about music,
the first thing that comes to mind
is just the idea of taste and
how deeply intimate that is
with our sense of selves and
your sense of social identity.
So I really wanted to
do something about that.
And then getting from that
to Kenny was pretty obvious.
So an exploration of why
Kenny G is the most popular
and successful and best-selling
instrumentalist of all time
and why that success makes
a certain subset of people really mad.
That's a hard lick. I just
played it really well.
Lane gives the critics their due.
To many of them, Kenny G is
offensive because he seems
fundamentally uninterested
in the musical tradition
that he has come to define
for millions of people
around the globe.
I spent a lot of time with Kenny
and it kinda didn't matter
how many different ways
I asked him what he was up to
when he was creating these songs.
He was just like, "I don't know.
It's pretty. I like it."
Most artists have a whole set of things
they're thinking about,
like who your audience is,
and who you're in conversation with,
and what histories you're drawing on.
How are you innovating? How
are you making something new?
Kenny just isn't engaged in that.
And I think it's his utter
lack of interest in jazz.
Kenny G does not know anything about jazz.
So what do the people
like who love Kenny G?
I think the most important thing
is that it's music that is useful.
It's useful in their lives.
I think life is hard and
there's is nothing wrong
with wanting something to relax to
after your 10 hours at
the factory or whatever.
It's useful music because
it doesn't have lyrics.
It doesn't get in the way.
You can put it on in the background.
So people study to it,
they meditate to it.
They run to it. They make love to it.
They get married to it.
They've used it to put babies to sleep.
Anesthesiologists use it before surgery.
It helps get the heart rate down.
The Chinese government
uses it to send people home
at the end of the workday.
It is a supremely functional music,
which is interesting
because it's referred to
by another critic as musical furniture,
which I think is actually pretty apt.
It's easy to forget that most people,
when I tell them that I made a film
about why people hate Kenny G are like
"Who hates Kenny G?
Everyone loves Kenny G!"
Recent interviewed you a few years ago
when your incredible documentary
"Hail Satan?" came out.
That is a film about a group
of Satanists who are pushing
for equal representation
of religious icons
in the public square.
What's the connection there?
The joke way of putting it would be to say
after I made a movie defending Satanists,
I thought to myself
"Who do people hate more than Satanists?"
But that's not really true, of course.
It's more like I am I
think what I'm good at
and what I think what I'm good at
and what I'm trying to
do often with my films
is find really entertaining
funny ways to talk
about really serious
issues that I don't think
a poe-faced delivery would
get a big audience for.
And I want people to be
able to change their minds.
I want people to be willing
to change their minds
and I love that.
I love the feeling of
finding out that I'm wrong.
Not everyone does. I love it.
I'm trying to engineer moments
where it's like destabilizing for people.
I think one of the most
insightful criticisms
is a jazz ensemble is kind
of a call and response thing,
it's equal parts, everybody's
playing against each other,
and that Kenny G, it's just Kenny G.
It's just the saxophone.
Everybody else there is
there to support him.
Yeah, it's a solo-
He says, "It's not sex.
It's masturbation."
The most quoted line in the movie.
But that guy is also
a ridiculous character of a jazz.
Why should jazz have one meaning
that is described by some old white guys
who are really upset that
this Jewish guy from Seattle
is selling so many records
and is like fucking with their little pot.
Yes.
I agree with you that that is
a question the movie raises.
I can see it both ways.
I'm trying to play down the middle.
I'm trying to like lay out
a kind of like banquet
of discussion topics.
Lane's film's all proceed
from the assumption
that she doesn't have all the answers
and that she doesn't know the best way
for other people to live or
the best music to listen to.
It's no coincidence that she's
a longtime reader of Reason magazine.
I started subscribing to
Reason when I was in college
and I went to Vassar.
So it like came in the mail.
I would like put it
underneath all my other mail
to bring it back to my dorm room.
But honestly, in high school,
I remember we had a politics class
and you were supposed to
choose Democrat or Republican
to be part of the debate or whatever.
And I just like didn't like it,
I just didn't know what to do,
'cause I was like, "I
don't want either one."
And my teacher was like,
"Okay, well there's this other thing."
And I think on some level I
probably was attracted to it
because it made me feel special.
I'm the one person here who doesn't wanna
go along with the crowd.
I was like, "Yeah, society
needs people who are annoying,
who stand outside and say,
'Yeah, but what about this?'"
And I've always identified
with that kind of personality.
And I do think that is somewhat
of a kind of libertarian personality type.
But as far as my etiology
goes in the films,
I think to the extent that
there is etiology there,
it's very much about humility.
I think I'm a genius and
I should run the world,
but I would never wanna do that
because I actually don't
think that my ideas
are better than other people's ideas.
I mean, I think I have ideas
about how I want to live,
but I'm not interested in
imposing them on other people.
I think I would more say
that I'm asking people
usually to consider issues
from different points of view
and to acknowledge that probably
they're going to gravitate
toward one of those.
So you might watch the
Kenny G film and think
the critics are villains.
You might watch the Kenny G and think-
Kenny G is history's greatest monster.
Yes, someone else would
watch it and find him
odious and unacceptable.
I am thrilled to make a film
that allows for those readings.
I really am not trying to tell
people what to think, truly,
but I do think that there are things
that I'm passionate about foregrounding
that I wanna force people to contend with.